with the Passat GTE Volkswagen has
brought out its first midsize plug-in
hybrid model since the golf GTE the
alternative drive is available for both
sedan and station wagon models in purely
electric mode the car is almost silent
and has zero tailpipe emissions that
lets it into all emission free zones and
cities
vinegars artistic I know Dyson Hofer
praises the GT e--'s fuel consumption
goal of under two liters the hybrid goes
up to 50 kilometers on electric power
alone so if your workplace is closed and
you have an electric outlet there you
can go from Monday to Friday without a
drop of petrol at least in theory now
we'll see the reality the GTE comes with
its own trim line the standard features
include LED headlights
in terms of safety the GTE is at the
forefront it's equipped with a number of
standard assistance systems to support
the driver like the front assist system
that monitors the traffic situation and
even breaks in an emergency as
final-season connectivity is an
important issue for modern vehicles a
clever watch app enables him to locate
the GTE on a giant parking lot and make
sure it's locked he can tell the
temperature start up the
air-conditioning and check if the car is
charging so he knows how far he can
drive Optus autocratic live inverts
Tampa divisive artist and a feat of Anka
that may still look like gadget tree for
its own sake but it's a forward-looking
element the developers envision a car
that can locate its own charging station
the driver would get out of the car
leaving it to go autonomously to a
charging place in the vicinity
but for now the driver at the wheel is
still an indispensable component I note
says the Passat drives like a good
gasoline engine car when the electric
motor and the combustion engine are
working together it gets quite a lot of
speed and efficiency boosting display
shows what the driver is doing well or
not so well that includes fuel wasting
moves like pointless acceleration
unnecessary use of the seat heating or
air-conditioning or poor defensive
driving the Passat GTE has a system
output of 160 kilowatts VW reports the
NEDC consumption is just one point six
liters of fuel and twelve point eight
kilowatt hours of electricity per 100
kilometers combined co2 emissions are
just 39 grams per kilometer in reality
though the values deviates somewhat from
those claims Chester says the Passat can
go around 1,000 kilometers on a full
tank he calculates an average fuel
consumption of 3.5 to 4.5 liters under
the hood the classic 1.4 liter
turbocharged gasoline engine gets
support from an 85 kilowatt electric
engine
the rest of the technology is neatly
stowed away in the floor that's left the
trunk with lots of space and room for
the charging cable in the double boot
floor line hook calls the Passat GTE an
environmentally friendly and comfortable
alternative for short distance commuters
who can make it to work and back purely
on electric power it's only on longer
motorway trips that consumption Rises
when the petrol engine takes over but
sales of hybrids are rising steadily
worldwide at the moment they lie at
200,000 vehicles a year that's expected
to double in the next three years and in
2022 there should be three million
hybrids but with a starting price of
45,000 euros that GTE
is expensive possible government
subsidies are unlikely to change that
our car tester montes current says the
name BMW evokes associations of rakish
convertibles sporty coupe ace and
rear-wheel drive for taking curves may
be also luxurious sedans or Ronnie SUVs
SUVs about that but this is this a BMW I
want it says you'll check it out there's
only one way to find out but BMWs first
family five seater will have to work
hard to convince our tester
Psychonauts Montes says one rule has
been in place for generations BMW has
rear-wheel drive the 2 Series active
tourer is the first BMW to break with
that tradition it usually comes with
front-wheel drive if desired you can get
it with all-wheel X Drive and that's not
only sues your conscience and your pride
because who wants a front-wheel drive
BMW the car also handles better the 2
Series active tourer with the
gasoline-powered engine we're testing is
the most powerful of the series 4
cylinders give 170 kilowatts of power to
the all-wheel X Drive the 8-speed
steptronic transmission lets you sprint
from 0 to 100 and 6.3 seconds and fuel
consumption is only 6.5 liters per 100
kilometers Montes says BMW normally
Orient's the whole front seat toward the
driver and to a degree that's true of
the 2 Series active tourer the GPS
monitor in the middle is turned to the
driver as are its controls below it
otherwise the front seat is roomy and
open Latif often this cockpit as for the
back seat it's roomy enough to plenty of
legroom and Headroom but the space can
be reduced by moving the backrest
forward that may be less comfortable for
adults but of children are sitting in
the back it won't bother them and this
car was designed with young families in
mind if the children have lots of
luggage then they have to sacrifice
legroom then you can now feel the Pegman
name boy then the field plots for you by
no montes is pleased at the range of
materials used in the 2 Series active
tourer foamed plastic over the
instrument panel whether on the
dashboard hardwood trim on the door he
says it looks very stylish the best
thing about the active tour is the space
it offers the trunk holds 468 litres and
can be expanded to 1510 litres more than
enough for the kids toys the exterior is
convincing too with its compact
dimensions and dynamic design the cars
message is clear this vehicle is
designed to accompany active people
the father Manta says the suspension
system is so taught that he notices
every little bump in the road every
manhole cover
he says BMW ought to offer adaptive
suspension for the softer setting the
version of the 2 Series active tourer
that we tested cost 40,000 euros in
Germany a stiff price for an atypical
BMW
either fuga given the 2 Series active
tourer is clearly a BMW says Montes good
craftsmanship good materials in the
interior the multimedia system and its
controls everything is very high quality
but he's not sure that he'd prefer it to
its competition and sports inverter in
the meantime mother says coffee has
gotten cold Hyundai is replacing the
i-35 the compact SUV will be renamed to
son that's an old acquaintance from 2005
but now it looks more like a Santa Fe
the car was developed mainly in whistles
time and it's being built in the Hyundai
works and no seviche Czech Republic
prices start at twenty-two thousand four
hundred euros VW rolled out its first
camper for the German market in 1988 it
was based on the t3 now here comes the
California based on the new t6 and three
equipment lines
the base model beech the mid-range coast
and the top-of-the-line ocean prices
start at forty one thousand four hundred
thirty euros for the California beach
with a sixty two kilowatt diesel engine
there are cars so powerful that only a
professional racer should drive them
there are cars so fast that they
shouldn't be allowed on public roads
thank goodness the new Audi r8 v10 plus
isn't one of them even if it is very
fast the new version is simpler to drive
even for inexperienced drivers it's a
lot more torsionally stiff so from a
racing drivers point of view it's 40%
stiffer across the chassis so when you
turn the response is more immediate the
feedback to the driver you really feel
like you're in the car and connected to
the car and the other thing is it's 15%
lighter and so now with 1555 kilograms
of weight it's a light little agile
sports car and Allan McNish of Scotland
knows what he's talking about he won the
24 Hours of LeMans raced three times
today he has put on his racing overalls
to test the r8 v10 on the Portimao
circuit in southern Portugal Olek
Hackenberg out a board member for
technical development calls the v8 n +
the company sportiest vehicle it has a
10 cylinder engine with 619 horsepower
and 560 Newton meters of torque it
accelerates to 100 and 3.2 seconds with
a high top speed of 330 kilometers an
hour so it's quite a sporty machine just
the thing for customers who like to pull
out all the stops on a racetrack the
cars silhouette has been revised only
slightly with slightly sharper contours
the changes in exterior design are quite
moderate
Hackenberg says how D is enthusiastic
about this vehicle that was developed
together with a real racing car the r8
LMS which demonstrated its qualities as
Victor in the 24-hour race on the
Nurburgring Hackenberg is proud and
happy about such a premiere this
animation shows how close the
street-legal
r8 is to the racing car
the space frames of the cars correspond
to 95% the difference lies in the LMS is
rhobar the two engines are also almost
identical
one interesting fact due to the
regulation this car has less horsepower
than the street car
it's got 30 less horsepower by
regulations so we've had to put air
restrictors onto it
but when you you know you talk about DNA
and I've been with Audi since 2000 and
all of the rod cars have the DNA of the
racetrack that engineering led so
therefore we try to make the car the
best that can be on the racetrack and
then that technology comes onto the road
cars the four camshaft engine works
smoothly with the 7-speed dual-clutch
transmission the 1555 kilo two-seater
accelerates from 0 to 100 and 3.2
seconds and at 200 kilometers an hour in
just nine point nine seconds thanks to
the Quattro four-wheel drive system od
says the r8 v10 consumes twelve point
three liters per 100 kilometers that's
13% less than its predecessor but
according to the board computer Allan
McNish burned about twice that even away
from the racetrack the r8 is an
old-school sports car Howdy's early
Hackenberg says the car is easy to drive
and is very very fast you don't need
much time to get used to it it handles
well from the start it's a user-friendly
car and is easy to control even at its
limits and in power drift and that's
what sports car buyers want the interior
and it's functional design needs some
getting used to the sporty steering
wheel has plenty of functions the
virtual instrument panel familiar from
the TT has been expanded to include a
performance mode
you know for me the radio I switch off
and I just listen to the v10 the the
sweet the harmony of that on the up
shifts and the down shifts in it and it
gives you that real racing sensation and
in Germany you can enjoy that sensation
for just one hundred eighty four
thousand seven hundred euros
there are many opal atoms and they are
almost all different that is because the
possible combinations of colors and
other customized elements make for 70
thousand unique atom models
now there's a new option just made for
the summer the swing top fabric sunroof
gives the Adam rocks an open-air feeling
oh boy Schaefer shows us the swing top
roof of this open-air model
he says the fabric folding roof opens up
way behind the driver so that the
pleasurable feeling of the atom is
joined by a pleasurable fresh air
feeling company at mid fleshly fun
reading too convenient a push of a
button and five seconds later the city
car is open to the sky the triple
layered fabric mixture with a core of
neoprene rubber moves back to the
c-pillar
whether that's enough for a real
convertible feeling as something
everyone has to decide for themselves
the roof is not completely new it was
already available for the Adam rocks
off-road version but now the normal atom
comes with a swing top and brown or
black because the roof doesn't retract
completely it doesn't have to be stowed
away that's an advantage because the
trunk doesn't offer much room
deco faux fur tester Ronnie left stack
the trunk is definitely too small
although two cases of bottled water
would probably fit another problem is
the high loading sill he had to lift his
bags rather high but once he did they
fit quite well the roof can be put up or
down while driving at speeds up to 140
km/h the Adam open air we tested was
fitted with a 85 kilowatt one liter
Ecotec turbo engine pushes the atom up
to a maximum speed of 195 km/h on the
Autobahn
Ronny feels that for a minicar the atom
handles quite well in traffic and offers
an especially good turning circle and
for a three cylinder turbo the engine
produces a very pleasant performance for
the soft-top version many different
interior configurations are available
the play of colors and contrast is
striking from the steering wheel to the
dashboard even to the parking brake the
gearshift lever and door panels
everything is done in a two-tone color
scheme
but Ronnie especially likes about the
oval Adam is the many ways to
personalize it that guarantees the
buyers a card just the way they wanted
but then it might complicate matters
when the first owner tries to sell it as
they say different strokes for different
folks and all the mixing and matching
comes at a price
aside from the extra cost for the color
and design options the soft top adds
3,240 euros to the base price in Germany
the Schloss bends beg classics is a
comparatively new classy car event it's
only been taking place for seven years
but it's already advanced to one of
Europe's top events that's thanks in
part to the participants more than 100
lovers of vintage cars take part in the
historic rally through the hilly
countryside near Cologne
classy cars worth millions aren't the
only eye catchers here this 1959 BMW 600
Healey captured the hearts of the
onlookers it's driver engineer and
Souter tells us the story of the micro
car he was in France with a friend
traveling with 10 horsepower Heinkel
cabina micro cars and decided to improve
on the design with a door in the front
and a bit more power he's proud that the
only two cylinder car in the field won
third place two years ago he's hoping to
repeat that this year but says it'll
depend on his co-driver he says it's
great here and many of the rallies you
have to constantly watch your location
while here he'll be able to get a
glimpse of the landscape
afterwards the cars will be presented at
a high-caliber Concord elegance but some
of the participants have found the rally
quite exhausting she says she felt a lot
of pressure because her husband takes
the whole thing quite seriously
she herself drives for fun while he is
more ambitious but she says they're
happy to be here Arthur tells us about
their car the opel admiral was built in
1938 when the body by Glaser
he says the special thing about this
model is that the top is completely
retractable compared to beetle tops with
their giant bulge he says the car was
discovered as a towing vehicle in
Montevideo there was a crane sticking
out of the back axis after much
searching he was able to find an
original car radio from 1938
the confession you got a massage
this 1953 Goliath sport is the first
series vehicle with direct
fuel-injection the two cylinder engine
and this elegant sporty coupe a only
reaches 32 horsepower but since the car
only weighs 830 kilograms and gets a
dynamic 120 km/h there are only two of
them left today each of these vehicles
has a special atmosphere and a special
story that the owners are happy to tell
a horse 8:53 from 1935 this convertible
was a sporty addition to horses palette
of clunky upper-class saloon cars the
Kaba
I'm the Montford shrugs tells us how he
commissioned an English vintage car
dealer to find a model like this the man
didn't even know the horse brand existed
if he asked Porsche how do you spell it
and then he located it in a barn in Ohio
an American general had brought it to
the US after World War two and driven it
around until 1953 you believe Tata meet
cotton born in u.s. are on this town of
Bastogne saloon the driving from fatigue
a farm bought the horse 8:53 was
considered one of the most beautiful
cars of its time after seven years of
work it's been restored to its former
glory
it gets reactions very different from
the BMW 602 de says a woman told him how
she and her husband drove to Italy on
their honeymoon in this car 56 years ago
he says it's practical for old people to
reawaken youthful memories
which may explain why it's drivers get
the jury special price for the most
original vehicle at this year's loss
bents bag classics